what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are officially getting into
blackest night the Blue Lantern flash
story and this is really cool it's
actually one of the coolest tie-ins to
the blackest night event but we're gonna
have to cheat a little bit technically
speaking issue number three of this
story takes place after blackest night
issue number five but that's fine we're
just gonna you know cook the books a bit
and then just sort of throw it in there
but there is a little bit of backstory
that I want to talk about before we get
into this namely the character of Barry
Allen and the character of Bart Allen
now when it comes to the character of
Barry Allen he was the second version of
the flash Jay Garrick showed up in the
Golden Age of comics eventually Jay
Garrick just disappeared one day and
Barry Allen took his place and then DC
used the disappearance of Jay Garrick to
explain the existence of the multiverse
and so on and so forth but Barry Allen
as we know him died during the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths in 1985 and in
his place came Wally West who had been
kid flash up to that point but was
basically aged up to be an adult and
then went forward as the main flash
under the writing of Mike Barron and
Mark Waid from 1985 86 87 going all the
way up to 2009 when Barry Allen came
back now for those of you guys who are
following our DC videos where we talk
about the events of like Final Crisis
for example Final Crisis is the story
that details the return of Barry Allen
the general idea here is that Barry had
been gone for 20 years he had basically
vanished nobody really knew exactly
where he went to it it wasn't until he
came back that we basically learned that
he had disappeared into the Speed Force
for some 20 years and was just out
running death but the idea was that with
wally west as the flash the goal was to
basically repeat the success of barry
allen and one of the things that had
made barry allen so popular was to have
a sidekick of sorts and so what DC did
is they created bart allen as this
descendant of barry allen and EA barred
Thawne all the way from the 31st century
and the idea was to basically bring him
to the modern day and then just teach
him to become a flash now this served as
part of a wholesale expansion of the
flash mythos meaning that as Mark Waid
continued to invent things like the
Speed Force and so on and so forth
weren't allen served as one part of this
huge expansion of the flash family but
the idea was that Bart Allen's
popularity was one of those things where
DC kind of looked at it and said okay if
we're gonna bring back Barry Allen we
can't have all these guys running around
got to find some way to get rid of Bart
and so what they did is they created a
story called the flash fastest man alive
and this is a story that takes place
after the events of Infinite Crisis but
before the events of Final Crisis what
fastest man alive did is it basically
said during the events of Infinite
Crisis Wally West had basically ran into
the Speed Force in order to keep
superboy-prime prisoner and that was
about it Bart Allen had gone in there
with him and you know a handful of
others up I think maybe was just Bart in
wall-e and then eventually Bart was the
only one who made it out but Bart was
older and then when they wrote fastest
man alive they basically had him killed
off he basically died against the Rogues
and it allowed DC after the events of
flash fastest man alive to bring Wally
West back into the main DC Universe
along with his kids who were older and
so again that was all part of the the
aspect of expanding and sort of shifting
things up the problem with this is that
writer Geoff Johns also loved the
character of Bart Allen and so the goal
was to bring him back yet again what
this does is it details or it really
just shows us that Bart Allen is already
back and that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to bring this up is just because
of the fact that this is going to
feature a lot of the character of Bart
Allen the other half of this is that
with the return of Barry after the
events of Final Crisis writer Geoff
Johns had written a story called the
flash rebirth and what it was designed
to do was basically be a giant retcon he
was designed to go back and say here is
an updated retelling of the origin of
the flash here's an updated retelling of
like Barry Allen's history so on and so
forth we ended up learning things like
eobard thawne the reverse flash had
actually gone back in time and basically
began instigating all these series of
events that would lead to Barry Allen
moving to Central City and then
ultimately becoming a forensic scientist
and then in turn being doused in
chemicals struck by lightning which was
actually his future self and then
becoming the flash and so these are all
the things that took place as part of
the flash rebirth story he was amazing
but ultimately at the end
eobard thawne was basically arrested and
thrown into iron Heights where he's been
ever since the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that remember
during the events of blackest night this
is basically all these black lantern
rings bonding themselves to the bodies
of characters who have been deceased
over the years who have died from any
number of different things now remember
the whole purpose of blackest night is
basically for DC to relaunch is DC
essentially giving rings to every single
character who's ever died reso
acting them and then deciding which ones
they want to keep and which ones they
don't but the idea is that with
everybody basically responding in their
own way superman/batman this sees the
return of eobard thawne now this is
where things really got hairy for a lot
of people who were reading this story
and didn't fully understand what's going
on
technically speaking the only way a
person can become a Black Lantern at
least initially it was believed the only
way a person could become a Black
Lantern is if they were deceased what
this story details is the idea that a
person can become a Black Lantern even
if they're not dead now this is not the
current day eobard thawne instead this
is eobard thawne from the 1970s this is
the version of eobard thawne that Barry
Allen killed before crisis on Infinite
Earths
back in flash number 139 in 1963 the
flash rider at the time John Broome and
the artist carmine infantino had looked
at the idea of creating a villain for
Barry Allen that would basically match
him in almost every conceivable way
really eobard thawne's served as one of
Barry's most notable villains in the
pre-crisis on Infinite Earths landscape
for around like 20 years and the whole
purpose behind this was like this
massive 20 years spanning epic that was
designed to not just introduce eobard
thawne as a match for Barry Allen but to
create this guy who was basically a
compelling villain one of the things
that DC had ended up doing is they
actually killed off iris West
and the goal was to basically just you
know give Barry Allen the possibility at
love with like a new woman there's
something along those lines the issue is
that Barry had actually found found love
with a new woman named Fiona Webb the
problem was that
eobard thawne being the film that he was
was constantly on a mission to take away
any measure of happiness at baryonic at
hat and so what iam our Thawne ended up
doing was actually going through and
trying to kill for you on a web or at
least that was the belief of Barry and
so in response there was a massive fight
there was a tussle and Barry broke the
neck of eobard thawne that's the version
that you see here as the black flash the
reason why we can say that is because
this version of eobard thawne this you
know black lantern reverse flash doesn't
know that very Alan died and doesn't
know that Barry Allen came back which
means this version of the flash died
before Barry did which means it's the
original Silver Age version of eobard
thawne but again it also creates a very
compelling instance because we're a
apart Thawne was supposed to originally
match Barry Allen almost every
conceivable way in this story he does
they're both men out of time the problem
with this is that Barry Allen realizes
that the black Lantern's feed on emotion
is how they feed their central power
battery and allow for nekron the the
entity of the Black Lantern Corps to
pass into the real world and so the only
response that Barry can actually offer
here is to basically show no emotion at
all to be totally devoid of any feeling
whatsoever towards eobard thawne now of
course is results of him just kind of
throwing him somewhere and then running
off to gorilla City now the cool thing
about this is that this picks up with a
character by the name of Sala var I
think it is and Sala var was a character
who appeared in the flash issues one
issue number 100
I think it was and he was designed to be
part of this introductory story with
gorilla grodd in the sense this Olivar
was the guy who was leading gorilla City
and it somehow gained the ability to
basically practice telepathy the problem
with this and even then back in the
pre-crisis on Infinite Earths era is
that gorilla grodd sought to do the same
thing and so of course this led him to
the introduction of Grodd Grodd
eventually gaining the same kind of
powers it's all of our had and then in
turn going on to essentially become a
villain and so on and so forth but the
idea here is that somewhere along the
line Sala var had died and when he did
he became a black lantern and so the
idea of Barry showing up finding one of
his closest friends means he begins to
start feeling emotions and when he does
it begins to power the central power
battery of the Black Lantern Corps now
remember the other half of this is a
black Lantern's locate people based on
the emotions they feel and so if Barry
Allen races off somewhere and then stops
feeling any emotion whatsoever
ultimately the black Lantern's won't be
able to find them but that's the caveat
to the nature of the black Lantern's
eventually fear will overcome or hope
will overcome some emotion even on the
most minut level will be felt and
ultimately that person will be located
and so that's why things are so
dangerous here is because of the fact
that Barry Allen is basically fleeing
for his life and despite his attempts or
his best efforts to basically try to
overcome this whole thing in the end he
basically ends up falling prey to these
various emotions but one of those
emotions is more important than others
now before we get into that I want to
sidetrack to the Rhodes for a second but
for those of you guys who were new to
the flash mythos they were just a
loose-knit band of folks who just didn't
like Barry once they started working as
a team then they just became the Rhodes
but the general idea here is that the
roster of the Rhodes has changed over
the years with the previous members of
the Rogues having died one of the most
important is a character named golden
glider now golden glider is actually the
sister of Kathleen Colt and the idea was
that when she died it was crushing for
his character and so having her return
as a black lantern is kind of
bittersweet because what it does is it
presents the opportunity that maybe he
can find a way to bring her back but
when it comes to Captain Cold when it
comes to him as a character he's pretty
ruthless and he's actually pretty smart
and so he's able to deduce relatively
quickly that emotions are what the Black
Lanterns feed on now the robes and the
flash are fire
on the same side now they're not
fighting together but they are on the
same side the other half of this is that
with necron being the living embodiment
of death which is to say the entity of
the death aspect of the emotional
spectrum the drive is to basically
always bring things back and really
Necron is more of like a social
commentary on the state of DC Comics as
opposed to anything else the idea that
superheroes die and then they always
come back is essentially this notion of
like nothing stays dead and so as almost
as though nekron represents this concept
this sort of unspoken ideology in comic
book fans Minds that like when a hero
dies they should stay dead they should
never come back the fact remains here
that with Barry Allen basically being
this sort of living embodiment of hope
ultimately he's chosen by ganthet of the
guardians of the universe and by saint
walker to become the newest host of a
Blue Lantern ring and this is cool
because we end up seeing Blue Lantern
flash and it's one of the coolest things
ever because when it comes to him being
the flash moving at SuperSpeed and then
being able to fly it's pretty awesome
the problem with this is that when it
comes to being a Blue Lantern you have
to feel hope 100% of the time whenever
you have the ring on if you don't the
ring will abandon you that's the nature
of the Ring the idea of Barry being a
Blue Lantern means Biddy's stuck facing
off against Bart Allen now this is why I
say we kind of jump ahead a little bit
because in blackest night number five
one of the things that happens is that
necron basically makes the argument Bart
Allen died he died against the ropes he
should have stayed dead
but he was brought back he needs to be
with me were all the dead people are and
so the idea was to basically bond him
with a Black Lantern ring and then bring
him back now there were a ton of other
people who were bonded with Black
Lantern race the whole Justice League
was bonded with Black Lantern rings but
the other half of this is that because
of the fact that the black Lantern's
basically homed in on different emotions
the individuals of sollum are the
individuals of eobard thawne they
basically are looking for Barry Allen
and so once they taste those emotions so
to speak and then realize they're tied
directly to Barry they immediately show
up and start running through now this
coincides with the arrival of Wally West
and so again we basically have this
whole flash family we have you know
we have Wally West and then we have Bart
Allen you know stuck as a black lantern
the problem with this is that remember
just because a person who was formerly a
superhero is stuck with a Black Lantern
ring does not mean that one it cannot be
overcome and to that they are powerless
one of the things that we've seen is
that these superheroes and supervillains
who have previously died and come back
as black Lantern's ultimately ended up
keeping all their powers in this
instance it's solve our going to the
same thing using his mental abilities as
a black lantern to almost subdue Saint
Walker and Barry Allen and Wally West
and Bart Allen and so on and so forth
but ultimately the other half of this is
basically dealing directly with the
concept of eobard thawne which is to say
how do you overcome a guy who is
effectively dead has the same powers as
a flash and is still able to you know
face off against each one of these guys
individually the idea is that in the
midst of all this because the Speed
Force is the one thing that connects all
speedsters together when Bart Allen
makes direct contact with Wally West
what is up happening is the two of them
speak directly with one another in this
instance it's essentially bart allen
terrified to speak to Barry Barry who's
somewhat terrified of Bart but Wally
who's effectively this go-between for
the two of them and that's the reason
why Wally was always one of the more
important versions of the flash and one
of the reasons why people love him so
much because Wally has experienced a lot
of growth he's also become wiser he's
become a little more aware a little more
seasoned to quote unquote well he
doesn't necessarily have that kind of
Barry Allen personality element he's his
own character standing on his own two
feet which fans have grown to adore and
so when Bart Allen is basically met with
the arrival of Barry Allen is almost
father and son in terms of how these
guys were talking to one another but
it's also Barry using the power of the
blue lanterns to effectively overcome
the power of the black lantern by
allowing a living human host to escape
the rain now the other half of this is
the aspect of eobard thawne himself or
at least the original eobard thawne in
the sense that when Captain Cold in the
robes and basically defeated the Black
Lantern versions of other versions of
the Rogues who existed and then in turn
discovered you know eobard thawne just
kind of hanging there out in iron
Heights captain Cole just through a
frozen grenade throws the whole thing
over and then it basically hit Barry
Allen off to the idea that effectively
this version this Black Lantern eobard
thawne and the one in iron Heights are
the same person but from two different
eras
time so again this is also DC hitting
home at the idea that you can have
reverse-flash come back endlessly
because in truth because he runs around
through the timestream so much he exists
in every single moment
so Barry Allen could defeat eobard
thawne as he exists right now and then
within a day have to fight him again
because he's all over the place in the
timestream he's basically made an
infinite number of replicas of himself
so the other half of this and the last
little tidbit really deals with digger
Harkness who used to be Captain
Boomerang and of course Owen and the
problem with this is that Owen is
basically the Sun and is this
desperation is to bring his father back
the issue is that the Rogues generally
have a rule the rule of the Rogues
is they do not kill women or children
instead they basically do whatever it is
they have to do to achieve their goal
but they do not cross that line Owen has
been sacrificing kids to his father
under the idea that his father just
needs to continue consuming and then
eventually will come back to his normal
self this of course is a ruse for his
father basically feed on the emotions of
Owen and continue powering the central
power battery which of course means Owen
gets what he has coming in the sense
that he's just pushed down into the well
by Captain Cold and then he's just
killed by his dad and that's really the
end of him but what it does is it sets
the stage for this sort of coming
together with these various members of
the fly family and the sense that it is
st. Walker of the Blue Lantern Corps
it's Wally West it's Bart Allen and his
Blue Lantern Barry Allen racing back in
order to gather forces with the Justice
League the Titans whatever superheroes
are left for the purpose of bringing
down necron and the Black Lantern Corps
but with that being said guys we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comments
explain and make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you